ce n'est pas une compétence que chaque hacker
possède salut, je suis Jeff Moss le fondateur
des conférences black hat et DEF CON
et membre du Conseil Atlantique de
la Commission mondiale pour la stabilité
du cyberespace l'ingénierie sociale est un
moyen d'obtenir des informations des gens
qu'ils ne fourniraient normalement pas une
attaque d'ingénierie sociale [Music] ce qui va
se passer est que le méchant va essayer de
vous convaincre de révéler quelque chose une
information un anniversaire un mot de passe et
ils le font de plusieurs
manières vraiment ingénieuses parfois ils vont faire appel
à vos émotions aidez-moi j'ai oublié
certaines informations vous seul pouvez m'aider s'il vous plaît
fournissez ces informations et
vous serez une personne formidable pour le faire
et donc ce que font les ingénieurs sociaux,
c'est qu'ils essaient de créer un
environnement où le  la chose la plus facile
à faire pour vous est de leur dire l'
information et de vous sentir bien pour
avoir l'impression que vous aidez ou que vous vous
débarrassez d'un problème avec vos impôts,
mais en réalité, ce que vous faites, c'est que
vous êtes  fournir des informations qui
les aideront à commettre une fraude
[Musique]
et ce que nous avons vu récemment, c'est qu'il s'agit
davantage d'une arnaque téléphonique où vous
recevez un appel, le numéro de téléphone peut être
falsifié, vous répondez au téléphone en pensant que c'est
peut-être votre banque et en réalité  c'est
quelqu'un qui se fait passer pour votre banque et cette
communication vocale cette interaction
permet à l'ingénieur social d'être beaucoup
plus efficace car il peut écouter
vos réponses comprendre où
sont vos préoccupations et vraiment s'attaquer à peut-être
vos peurs cela a évolué
il y a même eu des études pour montrer
que peut-être que ces attaques peuvent être
automatisées avec des voix générées par ordinateur,
vous pourriez donc subir une
attaque d'ingénierie sociale et ce n'est peut-
être même pas un humain Je ne sais pas si les médias sociaux
sont devenus un terrain de chasse majeur, mais
à tout moment beaucoup d'informations sont
disponible à propos de quelqu'un cela facilite
faciliter les attaques sociales peut-être que si
vous avez beaucoup posté sur Facebook je sais
ce que vous aimez ce que vous n'aimez pas peut-être que
je sais où votre enfant va à l'école alors
maintenant je peux peut-être créer une
excuse plausible pour vous appeler  les
attaques d'ingénierie sociale existent
depuis avant qu'elles ne soient appelées
attaques d'ingénierie sociale et je pense que ce qui est
différent maintenant, c'est l'échelle qui peut être
appliquée, elle peut générer une attaque de moteur maintenant
je peux attaquer n'importe qui sur la planète
parce que je peux appeler n'importe qui sur la planète
je  peut envoyer un e-mail à n'importe qui sur la
planète alors qu'avant c'était plutôt un
tête-à-tête ou peut-être que j'enverrais une lettre une
lettre physique mais à cause de l'échelle
d'Internet, la facilité de
communication fait toutes ces attaques
tellement plus facile
[Musique]
mais l'une des meilleures défenses contre une
attaque d'ingénierie sociale est de poser
des questions critiques oh vous êtes avec l'
Institut financier puis-je vous rappeler
je suis occupé en ce moment mais je vous rappellerai
à votre  bureau dans une demi-heure
quel est votre numéro de téléphone ou quelle est votre
extension normalement dès que vous le ferez ils
commenceront à trouver des excuses eh
bien je ne serai pas là dans une demi-heure oh
vous devez le faire cette seconde et vous
pouvez commencer  pensant attendre une minute
quelque chose ne va pas si la banque a besoin de ces
informations, elle peut attendre une demi-heure
Je n'appelle pas le numéro qu'ils me fournissent
J'appelle le numéro en ligne ou le
numéro que j'ai dans mon adresse et donc
je pense cinq 10  dans quelques années, la
génération qui a grandi dans cet
environnement sera beaucoup moins
sensible que les personnes qui n'ont pas
grandi dans cet environnement, nous sommes donc au
milieu d'une sorte de
prise de conscience générationnelle autour de ce type d'escroqueries